my question and the reason I bring that  up is do you believe the Western media  that Ukraine is winning  this is a I think a topic worth  discussing because we might see opposing  viewpoints on this as we were kind of  talking about this subject before the  show there's there's a lot of  circumstantial evidence there's there's  the understanding that there's a lot of  propaganda a lot of disinformation but  we also have to understand that the  ukrainians were practicing and drilling  for this ever since 2014 on their  territory they have the latest  technology they have night vision they  have thermal they have satellite  technology they have GPS coordinated  weapon systems they have training from  CIA covert Ops Special Forces soldiers  that were there since 2014 setting up  the groundwork for this Invasion as the  U.S corporate media was literally  cheering on and setting the groundwork  to make everyone hate Russia so this has  been in the works for a very long time